it's true that the my attempts are
generally explicate the externalist
story as alex pointed out i used to
semantic terms and they do need to be
cashed out but but it seems to me
representation is carries quite a lot
less semantic baggage than meaning or
reference and right and so if there is
systematic if i if there's if there's
systematic response in my behavior
mediated through other systematic
processes in my brain and strong that
strongly call very with syntactic
changes in the various linguistic
entities that we use for this for
information exchange and the results of
course covariance that covariance those
coverings patterns are repeated in to
people with whom my interlocutors all
that systemic covariance just is
representations that's the basis of
representation version that avoids the
term representation I highly recommend
the recent book by my colleague ray
jackendoff called a user's guide to
thought and meaning which summarizes and
his book foundations of languages I
think a masterpiece but is a very hard
masterpiece to work your way through so
his book the users guide to thought
meaning is his enquiry humor up the
treatise very difficult nobody read it
then he wrote an inquiry to get people
to pay attention and they did raise
written the users guide and it is clear
is about and he's extracted it from all
of the infighting of the Chomsky ins all
of that stuff is just
cancelled out it's not there and he just
lays out with you which looks at what
has to happen so that language can have
meaning and he points out the
philosophical theories that don't go
through the psychology and the
neuroscience in the brain are tying to
hint to both hands behind their back
here's a here's a parallel that that
some people will get right away and they
might really like think about evo-devo
in biology one of the evo-devo people
say they say oh you evolutionary
biologists you go out right you go
immediately one step from the gene to
the phenotype you leave out all the
DeVos stuff and that just isn't good
because the diva stuff makes a huge
difference and a lot of evolutionary
psychologists say well you know we
thought we could sort of finesse all
that Devo stuff and and we really can do
the mapping directly from the gene to
the phenotype fifteen motivic features
well
there's differences of opinion about
that that Devo seems it seems to be a
lot of truth in Devo
now here's what Ray's do he's saying to
the philosophers who have their semantic
model theories which grow right from the
word to the world
says you're leaving the brain hound you
can't leave the brain huh you got to go
from the world to the brain word to the
brains of the world and if you try to
leave the brain up you'll never succeed
in telling the story well and then he
takes the brain and he articulates what
the specs have to be what does the brain
have to do and it's not david reminded
me of this the first day yesterday when
he was talking about how the brain
scientists they sort of don't have the
vocabulary even to talk about the high
levels of what the brain is doing and
this of course it goes back to David
Marr who also said you got to know what
the prob
as our that the rain is solving Ray's
book is an attempt to list the specs for
a working brain that can that can talk
about its world in terms that are
amenable to modeling in the rain soon
you know it's not it's not source code
you know all I need now to satisfy Alex
right we've got we've got this we've got
a rep for an ocean of representation
that's more innocent in reference right
but but it's still it's still
intentional so we've got to figure out
now how we can tell that a mechanical
story to get something going on between
the tracking system in the representing
organ the drain and the and those
physical tokens out there that we use
for coordination you know words for
example sentences now I take it key part
of the story in symbolic species is to
tell us what happened right in the
development of the in the in the in the
positive
phylogeny the brain right human breath
human brain that there's established
that that that basic ground floor
representational capacity Terry's story
is relies on
you